this is a businessman his business is
organized crime his products include
gambling narcotics vice loan-sharking
stolen goods labor racketeering and
goons for hire illegal gambling brings
in his biggest profits working capital
to finance other criminal activities
bribery and corruption of public
officials including some police officers
almost always accompany large-scale
illegal gambling the law enforcement
officer must avoid any such involvement
besides corrupting the community he is
sworn to protect involvement puts him in
personal jeopardy from local statutes
and from the Organized Crime Control Act
of 1970 this provides federal penalties
for public officials who conspire to
obstruct enforcement of local laws
against gambling
besides protection organized crime
provides layoff service for bookmakers
and numbers' operators two of the
largest illegal gambling activities this
call comes from the office of a numbers
operation the office manager may be
called a controller the officer dropped
checkup or counting-house the clerk's
inside men varying with the locality
here numbers bets are received and
tallied necessary records kept numbers
operations take bets on number groups
usually three in a given order digits
are determined by drawing as in policy
and bolita or by daily published figures
such as pari-mutuel payoffs Treasury
balances or stock exchange action
a lookout guards the outer door to the
numbers office but this and the other
elaborate security precautions are no
match for good police work a stakeout
team has had the building which houses
the numbers office under visual
observation binoculars pick up
significant details of visitors and
their cars a telephoto camera records
any suspicious activity to be later used
as evidence from this command post the
officer in charge maintains radio
contact with other police units prepared
to coordinate the coming raid with
citywide arrests of numbers salesmen the
number salesman is usually called a
writer he may work a regular route or
from a fixed place of business
most of the bets are small but the day's
total will be surprisingly large the
marker lists the three-digit number and
the amount bet markers are prepared for
secure delivery to the pickup man or
Runner
but number sellers need customers they
cannot long remain unknown to the police
winning numbers are called hits the
rider pays off his few lucky winners the
payoff on a straight three number bet
runs from four hundred to six hundred to
one smaller odds are paid on cut numbers
those heavily played because of
superstition or other reasons correct
odds should be 999 to one this
differential leaves a small percentage
for the writer huge profits for the
numbers operation the temporarily happy
winner is not the target the stakeout
waits for bigger gain the runner works
for the office or bank that owns the
numbers operation he controls as many
writers as he can handle he makes his
pickup like an ordinary customer to
avoid detection this time it doesn't
work his departure is noted and the
command post watching the numbers office
has alerted for his arrival
the runner reaches the innocent seeming
outer door of the numbers office the
lookout signal clears him through the
secured door inside unit five take the
lookout as planned
it is the last free action the lookout
will make for some time
the heavy door with its alarm system is
opened for the runner bringing in the
last of the day's bets the cash has
probably been routed separately to
another location called the Bank
headquarters or Clearing House the
clerk's have run up the totals and the
controller is ready to make any
necessary layoffs on heavily played
numbers through an agency of organized
crime a pari-mutuel payoff at a distant
track determines the final digit of the
winning number unit three lookout
neutralized move on in
police we have a warrant open up
please open up for my coming in judicial
approval may authorize immediate entry
without waiting for permission know what
method of entry is authorized in your
case all surveillance units proceed with
pre-planned arrests when there is no
longer danger of premature tip-off the
small fry of the numbers operation are
arrested
with the subjects from the numbers
office on their way
detectives are collecting identifying
and preserving the evidence some of it
partially burned but salvageable by good
laboratory work
the patrolman guarding the rear exit
during the raid brings in the important
records that literally fell into his
hands usable evidence results from good
police work planning the raid for
maximum evidence and for swift entry to
prevent its destruction effective
uncompromising law enforcement can make
numbers operations increasingly
hazardous and unprofitable illegal dice
or card games and gambling casinos are
often linked with organized crime and
the corruption which is its trademark
Gaming may be found in the plush
legalized gambling casinos of Las Vegas
it may also be found in illegal floating
dice games often set up in hotel or
motel rooms or their one-night stands
the equipment can be transported in a
suitcase every part of it from the
layout to the dice is suspect so are the
operator and his assistant some players
are regulars informed of the floating
location many are transients looking for
action and are easy to cheat safely to
find these marks the operator uses
steerers taxi drivers bartenders bellman
this driver is kept posted on the game
location and will get a fee or
percentage for the apparently half-drunk
well-heeled sucker he brings to the
scene of the action
a Confederate keeps watch in a separate
room ready to signal an alarm he may
also double a strong-arm man in case a
loser starts trouble it is - the
lookouts room that the steerer has sent
his passenger to the cold and
experienced eye of the lookout this half
drunk sucker looks ripe for picking
he gives him the room number of the
floating crap game and signals the
operator to expect him this time they
had the wrong sucker a suddenly sober
undercover detective his concealed mic
gets word to the team waiting below unit
five this is t1 the lookout at 5:14 has
an alarm buzzer in the doorframe I'm
proceeding to the game in 5:19 monitor
me and execute the plan when gambling is
established
unit five - all units proceed as planned
chips chips what's that around $20 about
20 big 20 there yeah [ __ ] hey here
we go here we go
there we go what's the point what's the
point eight okay
statutes concerning players in an
illegal game vary from jurisdiction to
jurisdiction there's no question
anywhere about the arrest of the
operator and his confederates besides
police testimony the case will depend
upon the considerable amount of physical
evidence and its nature it will be
carefully identified marked and
preserved for the trial good police work
by an undercover detective has put this
illegal gambling operation out of
business bookmaking is a most profitable
enterprise for organized crime which
provides two essential services to the
individual bookmaker
laying off his bets and furnishing the
information he needs to calculate his
odds the largest amounts of money are
bet on sports events football basketball
ice hockey and baseball horse betting
once the bookmaker stand by is next in
volume a successful bookmaking operation
depends upon rapid relay of odds line
information and results expert sports
handicappers often employed by organized
crime provide the analysis upon which
odds are based team and player records
and condition location of the game
probable whether the bookmaker uses
long-distance phone to get this
information fast and frequently he also
makes out-of-town calls to the bankers
of organized crime to lay off his bets
keep the book in balance
so that these incriminating toll calls
are not charged to the apartment he
rents for a few hours each day he has
attached to the telephone an electronic
device the blue box I call evasive
devices it violates telephone company
regulations the blue box circuitry
permits the user to make toll-free
unrecorded and untraceable calls
wherever direct distance dialing is
available through the blue box phone the
bookmaker gets the latest point spreads
on the college games he is booking on
football or basketball the better
usually wagers $11 on a pick'em basis to
win 10 point spreads reflect the
handicap or estimate of the competing
teams baseball bets are usually placed
at varying odds based upon the pitchers
for the day as well as the team record
to receive the incoming calls from
betters on which his livelihood depends
the bookmaker relies on several devices
which may keep his location or private
phone secret one is the backstrap a
simple circuit which connects the
bookmakers unauthorized extension to an
authorized and listed telephone at a
nearby but separate and clean location
another way to prevent his incoming
calls being traced or his location
revealed is by installing a black box a
somewhat more complex electronic device
it absorbs the electrical impulses on
incoming calls so that they do not
record at the telephone company's
central billing equipment this bookmaker
however uses the more sophisticated
cheese box to conceal his location and
private telephone number he maintains a
private phone elsewhere than the
apartment from which he works with a
number known only to him he keeps an
open line from his apartment to this
phone at prearranged towers known to his
customers they have a different number
to call connecting them with still
another phone which may be in an empty
or other clean location this call is
switched through the cheese box to the
bookmakers private phone also in a clean
location then during the hours that he
monitors this phone from his apartment
he can converse with the customer who
has called an entirely different number
to reach him other elements in the
elaborate screen of deception may be
markers or records on instantly
disposable water-soluble or flash paper
but even the tightest screen will not
shield against vigorous and
uncompromising police work informants
are a prime source for discovery of
illegal gambling they may be our police
payroll regular betters competitors or
disgruntled employees this is a
housewife who has discovered where most
of her husband's paychecks are going
betting on sports she gives the
detectives the accommodation number that
she knows her husband calls to make
wagers even then it is not easy to find
a bookmakers actual location the
telephone company will aid in tracing it
through the maze of electronic evasion
having located the apartment that the
bookmaker works from a few hours each
day they keep it under surveillance they
learn the daily routine and plan for a
legal yet fast entry when the action is
heaviest evidence most plentiful the
bookmaker is off the cheese box open
line with all bets in for that day he
finds that to balance his book and
ensure a profit he must lay off some
heavily played teams it is time to call
the bookmakers bookmaker almost always
an agent of organized crime lay off his
big business without it few bookmakers
could operate his heavy work over he
waits expectantly for delivery of his
daily sandwich
information leads to investigation
investigation to surveillance
surveillance to apprehension it pays off
armed with a warrant police planned
their raid when the maximum evidence
would be on-hand and with minimum chance
for its destruction
there is no cooperation from the
bookmaker but their continuing
investigation will uncover other
evidence the unauthorized electronic
equipment the testimony of the not so
innocent owners of the apartment they
find the water-soluble paper on which
the bets were written and a little black
notebook listing the bookmakers layoffs
and lineart sources they lead directly
to organized crime without organized
crime to bank numbers lay off debts
protect gaming and bribes some officials
and police officers illegal gambling
could be stopped you the officer must be
aware of the connection between illegal
gambling and organized crime only honest
aware and informed law enforcement
officers can bring the organized
criminal before the bar of justice only
incorruptible impartial and stern
justice can make him pay for his crime
you must be informed on the major types
of illegal gambling there emmos and the
applicable gambling statutes in your
jurisdiction
you must be trained in effective
techniques to discover the illegal
gambling operation to informants
observation and investigation to follow
the operation as close to the top as
possible to plan the arrests so as to
acquire and preserve the necessary
evidence for conviction